Speaker 1: All right, let's get into a breaking
story that many in the audience will appreciate,
and unfortunately, some in the audience will
be furious that I'm even talking about this.
There are new Kremlin papers which appear
to show Vladimir Putin's plot to put Donald
Trump in the White House important.
This doesn't mean that Trump and Putin met
to concoct this plan or that Trump was directly
involved.
The whole point is what has been said all
along.
For people who love to say Russia, Russia,
Russia said that Russia had a preference for
Trump because of the cartoonish and destabilizing
nature that his presidency would have.
And they worked to help him, regardless of
what Trump knew or participated in.
Documents suggest Russia launch secret multiagency
effort to interfere in U.S. democracy.
Go by what is said, not by what you imagine
I am saying and want to refute the reports.
Vladimir Putin personally authorized a secret
spy agency operation to support a, quote,
mentally unstable Donald Trump in the 2016
US presidential election during a closed session
of Russia's National Security Council.
According to what are assessed to be leaked
Kremlin documents, the key meeting took place
on January 22nd, 2016, with the Russian president,
his spy chief.
Since then, senior ministers all present.
They agreed a Trump White House would help
secure Moscow strategic objectives, among
them social turmoil in the US and a weakening
of the American presidents negotiating position.
How could anyone be surprised by this?
Put for all the people who say, David, you
love to criticize Putin.
Putin's brilliant, Putin's brilliant.
Russia is brilliant at this.
Of course, if you're Russia, you, China and
the US are the three major superpowers vying
for the next decade or two of supremacy among
that that group of three, what could do more
damage to the United States than electing
a cartoonish moron like Donald Trump?
Russia smart.
I'm not criticizing.
Of course, they tried to do this.
And unfortunately, the Republican electorate
and subsequently enough of the electorate
that voted in the general election fell for
it.
And Trump won.
It doesn't mean Trump and Putin met to plan
this.
That's not how intelligence operations work.
Russia's three spy agencies were ordered to
find practical ways to support Trump in a
decree appearing to bear Putin's signature.
These are the documents believed to now be
authenticated by this point.
Trump was the frontrunner in the Republican
Party's nomination race.
A report prepared by Putin's expert department
recommended Moscow use all possible force
to ensure a Trump victory.
This is also relevant because those saying,
well, Putin was involved even during the primary.
Increasingly, it looks like Trump surfaced
to the top of the Republican primary, thanks
just to the ignorance of the Republican electorate
that votes in the primary at that point at
which it seemed that Trump was in the commanding
position.
That's when Russia got the idea, hey, it would
be real.
Imagine the laughing stock that the US would
be if Donald Trump defeated Hillary Clinton.
Whatever your thoughts are about Hillary Clinton,
Western intelligence agencies are understood
to have been aware of the documents for some
months and to have carefully examined them.
The papers seen by The Guardian seem to represent
a serious and highly unusual leak from within
the Kremlin.
Let me propose something to you, OK, this
is this is speculation.
That's what we do.
This is an opinion show.
I want to just float an idea.
There seems to be agreement that these documents
are legitimate and there seems to be agreement
that this high level leak from the Kremlin
is unusual.
OK, I'm just going to float something here.
Recently, Joe Biden and Vladimir Putin met.
And as far as we believe earlier, even more
recently, Joe Biden and Vladimir Putin spoke
believe to be related to cyber attacks.
I'm just asking, is it possible is it possible
that part of the negotiation that took place
was that on the one hand, Biden would resist
a counterattack, shutting down a Russian oil
pipeline and in exchange, in exchange, some
documents would leak from the Kremlin, which
rarely happens, which would illuminate exactly
this about Russia's preference and work to
help Donald Trump.
I don't know.
And the really funny part about that is that
there is this idea that Trump is to have about
how you project power as a leader that comes
from Trump's cartoonish nature.
You push aside the Montenegrin president or
president, prime minister, I believe president.
And you talk in a certain way and you say
certain things about Kim Jong un and Putin
and whatever.
The real way that power actually works is
you don't stomp around and scream like a child
like Trump does.
It's by direct, undisclosed calls where you
say to a leader, hey, this this is how it
has to be.
If you want this, then you have to do that.
And it's just an idea because it is unusual
that such documents would leak from the Kremlin.
So is there anything surprising here?
There really is.
And no, this is this is everything we believed.
And that made simply logical sense.
And that is that that is what it is.
Now, of course, not surprisingly, the Kremlin
is responding dismissively.
Putin's spokesman, Dmitry Peskov, says the
idea that Russian leaders met and agreed to
support Trump in early 2016 is a great pulp
fiction.
The report number thirty two, 04 vid is classified
as secret, it says Trump is the most promising
candidate from the Kremlin's point of view.
There's a brief psychological assessment of
Trump, who is described as an impulsive, mentally
unstable and unbalanced individual who suffers
from an inferiority complex.
There is also apparent confirmation that the
Kremlin possesses kompromat or potentially
compromising material on Trump collected,
the document says, from Trump's earlier nonofficial
visits to Russian Federation territory.
The paper refers to certain events that happened
during Trump's trips to Moscow.
Security Council members are invited to find
details in Appendix five.
At paragraph five, the document states it's
unclear what the appendix contains.
It is acutely necessary to use all possible
force to facilitate his election to the post
of US president.
So nothing surprising.
Of course, there are people who are going
to say this is also part of the lie.
But, you know, for me, this has always been
there's not going to be any smoking gun of
Trump and Putin meeting anybody who's expecting
that, anybody who was even expecting the Russia
stuff to lead to Trump's removal.
As you can go back to April of 2017, where
I say that's the wrong expectation.
That's not how it works.
That's not that's not what this is.
But the clear motivation for Russia to make
the US a cartoonish, laughing stock by helping
Trump.
It's obvious it would be weird if Russia didn't
do it because it's such an obvious intelligence
opportunity.
Many countries would think of it, but wouldn't
have the know how or the means to carry it
out.
Russia's really good at getting themselves
involved in this stuff.
That's the that's the reality